Поцілунки, обійми нашвидкуруч та відліт.
Родичам або друзям, які проводжають своїх близьких,
тепер узагалі не можна заходити в термінал аеропорту.
Попри епідемію коронавірусу у пасажирів настрій бадьорий.
Ми їдемо в гості до дітей на весілля. Дітей не бачила два роки.
- Не боїтеся?
- Ні. А чого боятися!
Якщо є маски, рукавчики, то знижується ризик.
Ні, не боїмося.
Я думаю, на цьому рейсі люди такі, що вони нічого не бояться.
- Рейс куди?
- У Швецію. Люди трудоголіки, працьовиті.
Поки з аеропорту "Бориспіль" відправляються лише чартерні рейси,
здебільшого з сезонними робітниками.
Регулярне міжнародне авіасполучення Україна має відновити з 15 червня.
Але таким, як до коронавірусу, воно не буде.
Пасажирам тепер доведеться приїжджати на рейс не за 2 години до відльоту,
як раніше, а ще на годину-дві раніше. Це пов'язано
з низкою правил і процедур, яких слід дотримуватися в терміналі.
Зокрема дотримання дистанції під час проходження контролю.
Пасажирам рекомендують реєструватися на рейси онлайн
і здавати багаж на автоматичних стійках,
аби мінімізувати контакти в приміщенні аеропорту.
Також рекомендують не брати до літака ручну поклажу.
При купівлі квитка слід уважно ознайомитися з усіма актуальними правилами на сайті авіакомпанії,
оскільки деякі з них тепер обмежують кількість місць для рюкзаків
та маленьких валіз у салоні літака.
Це робиться для безпеки екіпажу і пасажирів, аби ті не скупчувалися у проходах.
Пасажирам слід бути готовими до кількох температурних скринінгів:
рамка автоматичного скринінгу на вході й перевірка біля гейту.
Вже проходив. Неодноразово. Все добре. Я живий та здоровий.
Завжди неможливо мати дистанцію.
Поки не було ще випадків, що ми з кимось зустрілися, хто заразився.
Якщо фіксується підвищена температура, то
біля стійок реєстрації рішення про дозвіл на подорож ухвалюють медичні служби аеропорту,
а в літаку - командир екіпажу, який ухвалить рішення відповідно до його інструкцій.
Процедура скринінгу може відрізнятися  в залежності від тієї країни, куди прямує пасажир.
Іноземні авіакомпанії можуть мати свої додаткові, більш посилені норми.
Про всі ми не знаємо. І слід сказати, що ситуація з цими нормативами постійно змінюється.
Практично кожні два-три тижні з’являються нові бюлетені,
які посилюють чи то послаблюють деякі пункти.
У разі, якщо в якогось пасажира симптоми захворювання
з’являються під час польоту, його відправлять на лікування в країні призначення,
а дані інших пасажирів рейсу авіакомпанія має надати місцевій владі,
яка вирішуватиме, як реагувати далі.
Ми продаємо не всі місця в літаку. Ми залишаємо останній ряд, як резервний.
Щоб у випадку, коли попри всі контролі під час польоту
в пасажира з’являються ознаки захворювання, його відсадили в останній ряд.
При цьому персонал компанії має стежити за тим,
щоб у проході, приміром, до туалету, не було черг.
Ми будемо просити-вимагати, щоб усі пасажири залишалися на своїх місцях у масках.
Харчування буде запаковане, вода в пляшках без стаканчиків, гарячих напоїв не буде.
Президент авіакомпанії МАУ радить усім пасажирам перед подорожжю
ретельно вивчити карантині правила в країнах призначення
і бути готовими їх виконувати: провести певний час в ізоляції,
якщо цього вимагають приписи країни призначення, надати дані про себе після прильоту,
зареєструватися в місцевих електронних системах контролю дотримання карантинного режиму
і - в разі порушення цих приписів - сплатити чималий штраф.
Також радять мати достатньо коштів під час поїздки і добру медичну страховку,
якщо раптом доведеться лікуватися за кордоном.
Є страхування. Без страхування ніяк.
Нам на місці все скажуть. Тому що наразі все пройшли, тести всі пройшли.
Тести треба здавати?
Ми собі здавали самі, за своїм бажанням.
Все стандартно.
Дотримувати дистанцію, 14 днів самоізоляції.
Знаю одне: кожна країна має право приймати нас чи не приймати.
Ми не в себе вдома. Ми в гостях.
Пасажирам слід також обов'язково зважати на те,
що розклад рейсів може постійно змінюватися.
Рейси можуть бути скасовані через зміни санітарного режиму
як в Україні, так і в країні призначення.
Чи повернуть у такому випадку кошти, залежить від авіакомпанії.
Деякі пропонують лише можливість перебронювати квиток на іншу дату або рейс.
Якщо прилітаєте назад в Україну, то процедура теж непроста.
Після прильоту, якщо пасажир не проходить температурний скринінг,
то відповідно до відпрацьованої санітарними службами процедури,
передбачено додатковий скринінг. Далі - або тести, або обсервація, або госпіталізація.
До 15 червня мають оприлюднити повний перелік процедури контролю.
За попереднім планом Мінохоронздоров’я,
в аеропортах для туристів буде передбачено умовно дві зони: зелена та червона.
Зелена - для приїжджих з країн, де ситуація з коронавірусом така ж або ліпша, ніж в Україні.
Червона - для країн, де епідемічна ситуація гірша.
Пасажири з червоної зони мають пройти 14-денну самоізоляцію і зареєструватися в додатку "Дія".
У іноземців тепер теж вимагатимуть медичну страховку.
Якщо дотримуватися санітарних правил, то все буде добре.
В Україні стільки прожили і не підхопили, то там тим більше, я думаю.
Літайте та й усе. Все добре.
Планується, що з 15 червня відновляться
міжнародні авіарейси до Туреччини, Кіпру, Болгарії, Азербайджану.
Поки що точно не відновлюватимуть авіасполучення з Іспанією та Італією.
Також Єврокомісія не рекомендує громадянам ЄС
до кінця червня виїжджати за межі Євросоюзу.
А уряд Німеччини, приміром, продовжив застереження
щодо поїздок до третіх країн аж до 31 серпня.
Це стосується понад 160 держав, у тому числі й України.